today we're going to be playing true or
false LGBTQ edition clue effects
honestly I'm just queer I know my
knowledge in the history of it not so
good for the longest time I didn't even
know how to refer to my own like
preference and sexuality is being
pansexual we never learned LGBTQ history
in school so yeah I didn't grow up with
like any openly queer people in my
family or really too many openly queer
friends so I didn't know a lot learn a
lot until like recently so I took gender
class in college in yes
I mean we have a 50/50 shot to get it
right Massachusetts with the first
States to perform legalized gay marriage
in the US ah I know this may be true I'm
gonna say true that's right I don't
think that's true I feel like that's
right
they're pretty liberal sweet we're
killing it right now we are walk out now
I was so confident in 2017 or it became
the first state to offer a third gender
option for driver's license and ID's
that is true the first thing I'm gonna
say true I'm gonna yeah we say true this
feels right to me
okay I remember that I feel like I
remember that being in the new store
that's true cool all right
incidences of gender identity or sexual
orientation based discrimination has
increased over the past three years
probably sadly I hope it's false but I
feel like it's true I think people are
actually getting better about it oh
that's kind of scary
a particular report opinions like may
have decreased but I do think that we
live in a time where it is a lot safer
to be openly cleared so I'm from Japan
yeah I'm sure Japan is like you get him
better so I don't
that's happening in Japan you know what
I have faith that things will get better
because the kids they get it
33% of series regulars on broadcast
television are identified as LGBTQ
characters that's a lot for us yeah that
can't absolutely not I'm gonna go ahead
and say it's true only because it feels
too specific to not be damn it I
understand it's not gonna be a hundred
percent but an ideal yes there are no
openly trans doctors performing gender
affirmation surgery there's gotta be one
something yeah there's the AH to be one
plus I'm gonna unfortunately say that
that's probably true which is sad
Carmilla a novel about a lesbian vampire
dream was published in 1872 a quarter of
a century before Dracula and I've never
heard of this this is just for hope I'm
just gonna go true yeah true that sounds
too obscured not to yeah yeah yeah also
how progressive so somebody make sure I
look this up later
I know what I'm doing tonight in 1972
Sweden became the first country in the
world to allow its citizens to legally
transition we I know it's Sweden so I
want to say true but nice 22 seems early
what am I still I'm no I'm gonna say
true because I have faith in Sweden well
good for Sweden shaded homosexuality was
not removed from the American
Psychiatric Association's Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual of Mental Disorders
until 1973 which sucks yeah I feel like
it's probably much later than that but
we have people like not too far removed
from our age who went through like
conversion there and they still exist
today it's crazy how in 1972 people were
recognized in Sweden to be able to
legally transition and for 1973 we were
still sitting it seeing it as some sort
of disorder
u.s. there's a secret gay slang language
called polari
I'm gonna go with true
I'll go with false just cuz I have no
idea Volare that is true if you don't
there is no once told me what what yeah
New Zealand was the first country to
legalize gay marriage I really think it
is I feel like I think that's true I
don't think this is true alright yeah
yeah and then though I had no idea it's
cool to live in a time where we have
access to so much knowledge and also a
time where our history isn't being
pushed aside yeah I learned a lot it was
really into I'm really excited about
this lesbian family yeah yeah I want to
read that and learn LaLaurie
[Music]
[Music]